how do you say hello in Swedish maybe we
should hi hi dear page my name's Lise I
used to work at IKEA hi I'm Tyler I
worked at IKEA for a year hi my name is
Jonathan I've worked at IKEA for 11
months and my name is Denzel and I
worked at Kia for two years and we're
gonna answer some of your burning
questions
okay are there any shortcuts or back
alley ways to get through the store
faster
there are shortcut there are tons of
shortcuts there's like little pillows
like by like a little furniture areas
instead like a little that's all
throughout this I love a baby like 10 or
15 shortcuts just look at the map there
marked pretty well they're just kind of
secret sometimes so the trick is you
have to look at no one ever looks up you
have to look up I'd like the blue map
every section is numbered so the little
dotted lines that connect the numbers
indicate shortcuts but they're also like
doors that are you can walk through
there for the employees but also like no
one's stopping you from walking through
them do you see a lot of couples
fighting in the store yes I also used to
work as a greeter so I would be like
handing out yellow bags to people and
saying welcome to ICAO habla so
sometimes I'd be doing that and
sometimes I'd be working at the checkout
so it's like I see the happiness of a
relationship
yes there was this girl standing in
lashes we can return with me and there's
another girl behind her in a guy tell me
why there's like a cheating scandal
going on and these two girls about the
fight in the parking lot the girl was
like I'll meet you in the parking line
hold the horn up you're not here no say
Walmart baby girl somewhere bad you
don't do that here honestly I think I
might have seen a breakup it was over
the plants so that they can get a little
if you want to know if you're a
relationship can stand the test of time
go to Ikea is your own apartment
furnished in IKEA products i new are
gonna give this question that we get
that question all the time
mine has a lot of I can't products I
can't it's still like a go-to for me
because it's just like so convenient I'm
in here so yes I do have some IKEA items
no my entire house is not IKEA items
because one I don't have time to put all
that furniture because I'm always at
work or yeah I have a ton of IKEA stuff
even before I work there all my stuff
was like yeah already i'ma say uh yes
because when I first started off I was
let me know if you live in LA you've got
to live you know you got it ya make work
I've got nothing else oh and we have
these little program at IKEA like you
can get like a little a discount and
like a little like a lot of crime yeah
but when you broke that's where you
going do you have to learn Swedish to
work at IKEA that's all I know unless I
guess you work in this we didn't store
in Sweden we always use the questions
like how do you pronounce this and I'm
like oh that is article number five two
four six three one seven two that's how
I pronounce it like nude I'm not even
gonna try it you know I I can't there's
people that do yeah but I can't when is
the best time of day to go to Ikea if
you don't want to run into crowds that's
like asking when's the best time to go
like LAX or Disney there is no best time
that's like asking what time you gotta
use the restroom yeah no definitely the
morning as soon as the store opens know
what you're getting run to that and then
run out because after like an hour the
lines are there don't go like weekdays
like 7:00 to 9:00 because like that's
not a lot people gonna work and that's
also like when people realize that they
need to like buy a whole house a lot of
people don't really know what time the
store opens so like if you know when it
opens be know when it opens unless it's
like a sale day cuz then when it opens
people are gonna be yeah yeah that's
chaos have you ever caught someone
sleeping on the displays I didn't work
where the actual displays were so I
didn't see anyone like in the bed area
but I did catch some people sleeping on
like the rag display like we have the
rag stacked up and they're just kind of
sitting on it and dozing off but you
know that counts as a display it's more
of just like desperation after a long
trip to Ikea there Angela need a little
quick fire he's like walked a couple
miles you
rest how many Allen wrenches do you own
I own a lot I don't know why but I
always feel like I need to keep them
afterwards just in case even though
they're coming every package I actually
took a lot because I needed them like at
that key I need a baby but they all come
in the package right but when you lose
them and you got thanks you know what's
with your house I don't have any I like
I'm blue I'm the opposite of you I lose
them every time I probably I like or or
five they're like Buffy pins like you
put it down and then it's gone like
you're in the middle of making something
and then all of a sudden you've lost the
Ellen IKEA furniture is not really made
to like put together disassemble and and
I put it back together it's like a one
shot view talk about the back yeah if I
make sure I like get it right get it
tight the first time what item is we
turn the most epic here anything that
has an Ikea tag on that they can find in
their house mom bid in dresses
oh my gosh all the time another great
place to shop in the store is the
section of like the stuff that has
broken stuff in it because this section
that's what it's called the edges
section yeah that is a great place and
it's stuff that because sometimes you
can find a bargain of something that
used to be on display but now they don't
like selling it in a box because it's
already made and it's so cheap and it's
already like being built for yes so some
of the items come in like multiple boxes
and so they'll just like pick up like
one out of four boxes you have partial
items yeah yeah do people try and stay
after closing hours or spin the night we
have a great LP team lost dimension and
they like scope the store they like as
like the last customers there they're
like you need to go
we love the night I've never seen that
per se but like I said if they did I was
probably one of those people always try
to come in right at none I don't
understand okay full disclosure I've
done it before I started working here I
started working there we do have people
who like stay way past closing because
they're still shopping and still in like
the self-serve
they're struggling how often do people
get lost every day every day that's
probably one of like the biggest
complaint not complaints but like oh my
god I got lost I didn't know how to get
out a lot of kids they get lost you so
sad yes when people get cocky and like
try like how though they're Google I
last one okay what is the most popular
food item and what would you recommend I
would say the chicken meatballs are
underrated
there's a salmon with this lemon dill
sauce Oh baby cinnamon buns I would say
breakfast it's very inexpensive and
really really good actually now right
they play they're like you want some
food we got you got you baby gosh okay
chocolate the taco there's also soup
yeah it is very creamy get the big gold
one I know it's bigger and I know it's a
little bit more expensive but you're
gonna thank me later they have this new
like ham pork chop who does know I know
yeah it's a new menu item I know things
have changed alright so in closing its
Ikea it's a big store so the key is plan
ahead bring it back bring your snacks
baby they expect to get lost maybe cry a
little bit have some emotional support
educate on the leash have a game plan
going into it because if you don't gonna
buy way too much stuff it can be really
our goal than going to Ikea but just
like make a day of it lean into it like
go get some food bring the whole family
along bring your family from out of town
we're going on I care you guys hey yeah
bring everyone it's a fun time
[Music]